foreign
[Music]
do you know the story of the princess
Issa
[Music]
was called the
it was said this child would stop the
madness of War
in a new age of peace and compassion
[Music]
I was given memories of a world I will
never see
loyalty to a King I cannot serve
and love for a child
which I could not save
D what do you think they want
found her
scar Giver
I am a child of War
I was taught that love is weakness
there is a difference between Justice
and revenge
very surprised to pay for your defiance
[Applause]
one moment
I do love this part
hold on but I don't want no trouble
we're not here to bring any
are you ready
you and I both know fear
afraid
[Music]
more shackles that bind us
the king is a man and a man can fail
but a myth
indestructible
[Music]
time has come for all that you loved
to protect each other we show them your
mercy
[Music]
who among you is willing to die for what
you believe
[Applause]
[Music]